welcome to this video smita 08 from the
US now the bangko some might be no need
these type of openings are very popular
in the u.s. it seems maybe due to the
Sun due to the large number of Justices
where you need to to win the wind almost
all games to get get anywhere maybe well
we quickly put a position on the board
that is considered to be excellent for
wine I'm getting huge pressure on the f
file let's see Queen d2 now rook f2f1 as
them this is the way to go or is it
Queen age 6 I think Rock f2s right I
think this is right it tries to play of
6mm okay this is a good square let's see
in order to break through here I need to
also always consider the most if I've
itself it's very direct but sometimes
necessary let's see if I've
hmm if I go look everyone thirsty you
might play Queen g7 yeah okay it may be
queen age six was premature okay it's
still it's still not bad at all I'm just
a much good guy here on their farm yeah
I guess 95
or maybe 27 but this is looking like the
most obvious move and now what now I
wonder about D 5 D 594 this sick sorry d
6 and 95 to break through yeah come I
need to do something quickly it's not
the type of position where you can sit
on your hands I mean this is the type of
position I think of strike while the
iron is hot I have everything in play
and he does not and I need the night
badly on d5 okay 95
so what is happening here if he goes
Bishop is 6 for example d3 is hanging
now still I need to take on f6 Knight
takes rook takes rook takes Queen d3
rookie 6 yeah probably i don't have much
choice I don't really see I'm a better
move rook f6 maybe look f 6 mm at the
end I'm taking with the night King f7
and then what don't see a move the
question is to see does he really
threaten it something or can I somehow
improve the position with the bishop
move or something check probably not
let's let's do that
group takes rook takes this is six
hanging as well so Queen takes rook
jakes yeah that's not too great i mean
out of this really bad opening i I
didn't really I didn't really get
something hmm I'm not sure what I did
wrong it really has a very bad
reputation this line and maybe queen age
six was mistimed was too quick okay
let's see he's taking now you know I
mean work g6 is not working so I
probably just need to take it him you
know and i can take you can take maybe
now i have okie 700p seven is a threat
may be queen d7 my rookie 524 m don't do
that 27 i would need to play look f6
okay but she needs to be a bit cautious
like Quincy for I have rookie seven
again yeah this is something check he
needs to let us look at okay
okay yeah he's may be relying on Queen a
fraud check but isn't this still a good
end game but before I'm thinking about
the end game let's let's briefly
consider here is there something better
I don't think so let's do that it's it's
good for one anyway you have to look on
the seventh it's not fatal for black
probably but and here's got the counter
play with f3 mm-hmm how to do that
yeah I rock d2.id f3 this is really come
to play ever take a seven look here be
to hanks and i need to address this okay
let's let's move the King up not going
on the first rank this doesn't make any
sense try to get near the f-bomb well
that's a good reply okay here i drew a
five probably
maybe I can somehow exploit the eff porn
but it's not not apparent how this
should be possible you know yeah this is
very Jewish simply check
yeah I probably didn't even try the most
testing continuation
check shown here after g3 I have zero
winning chances absolutely zero okay
it's a pawn but it's not not to win you
can just stay put I have no way to
improve just yeah just I could stay on
the second song would be would be easier
even so there's some way to try grow a
third time morning there's some options
there's no way I mean I could win on
time but what's the purpose I have no
way to to kill unless the sea porn i can
I can do nothing can just move the King
back and forth does not really make any
sense hmm check out here here's the
point probably where I need to do
something else mmm Group B same Rock the
eighth hmm maybe yeah this is probably
nonsense maybe it's better to do it's
like else i thanking me for the draw
yeah well i think this should be normal
but it's obviously isn't yeah i probably
Kim Ji Won
it's clear that his cat counter play and
maybe yeah maybe like that is something
like that yeah this is more promising
than what I played at least if it's
winning i doubt i doubt but that's
better that's better i'm not giving so
much girl to play turkey I need to look
up the opening this is this is really
not good but here here's probably around
here's the point where it gets it gets
where where needs improvement look
everyone immediately maybe I don't know
I need to look it up okay thanks for
watching